hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the Riga free
diagram three 2019 it's a young shift of
do that versus raffia mom in Europe now
we already said that we are going to
show another game and then gonna check
out the standings and to get all the way
to the quarterfinals a youngster to do
that eliminated Peter Svidler or in the
round prior to this one and chakra mama
D are eliminated the kneel do both so
both of them had pretty tough tough
opponents but it's still pretty much
only the beginning we still have the the
semifinals and the finals so it's really
an interesting game I will show this
photo so let's just enjoyed that for a
second there you have it it's not from
this game as mama Dario has the white
pieces here two of the classic games
have been drawn and this is a game from
the rapids but I do not have a photo of
of the game that we are going to show
this photo and also the photos of the
profile of the profile player for us on
the left our compliments of Nicky Riga
so let's just enjoy the game Duda opens
with Knight to f3 in the ready is on the
board
sorry about that with d5 bye mommy there
are of c4 e6 sorry not b4 c4 e6 and now
do the could transpose into something
like the Queens gambit declined but he
goes for b3 he continues with the i-beam
core defense will Knight to Knight to f6
Bishop to b2 by Duda and now Bishop to
e7 with III preparing d4 Mahmoud are of
castles Knight to c3 and now D captures
on c4 Bishop captures on c4 and now c5
and this is where the game gets really
interesting this position has been
reached a few times before and there
have been few attempts here d4 was it
was an idea here h4 was an idea or just
you know a nice King side castle but
here do that plays a move that has not
been played before he plays rook to g1
it's a new move already as a move eight
which is really awesome and now we have
a completely new game so what's the idea
well you can see dude as bishops are
slicing all the way to the Kings side
that those are very nice bishops and the
rook is now ready on g1
you know support the pawns advancement
the g4 g5 and start an attack against
the black king
so mom you're off says okay first I'm
gonna get rid of your bishop it's very
strong here with a six preparing b5 and
now do that continues with his plan with
g4 and b5 kicking the bishop away from
such a nice diagonal Bishop to e2 and
now Bishop to b7 mamedyarov
also puts his bishop on the very nice
diagonal Duda continues with his pushing
of the pawn on the Kings side with g5
Knight to d5 and now if you capture you
yes you do have a nice position the
bishop here is open but it's not like
you can use it it's very hard to imagine
that white can somehow start an attack
here without actually pushing h4 h5 and
gg6 it's unlikely that the attack will
happen so here Queen to be won by Judah
his idea is that if Knight captures on
c3 which is uh well probably what black
wants to do then he's gonna capture with
the bishop and he wants to play Queen to
b2 and pressure g7 this way but mama D
ro isn't interested after Queen to b1 he
just continues developing pieces we have
Knight to d7 and now Knight to e4 by
Judah avoiding this exchange and now
opening up the bishop here for the
moment you cannot contest the bishop as
the opponent g5 really does a nice job
of preventing this bishop coming to f6
Queen to c7 getting the Queen into the
play connecting rooks and now rook the
g4 by Judah adding another defender to
the knight here also maybe the rook can
come to h4 in some lines may be pressure
on h7 who knows but all in all it's a
very nice rook lift however you should
always check if something like Knight to
f6 works I mean if it works you should
play it and here if black was to
actually capture with the Jeep on it
would work here black has just lost its
check from the rook once you move the
King then you capture the bishop again
with check and once the rook is captured
the black is just busted the problem is
after Knight to f6 check mom you're
often captured with the night and then
there's no problem
G captures Knight captures and even
though you have a semi-open G file for
your rook it's very hard to actually
start attacking here
your queen is misplaced you can't really
get the other look into the game your
king is still in the center lights for
Bishop not doing all that much so it
will be very hard to do to start an
attack here
so after Queen c7 we have worked the g4
by Duda and now II five by Mamedov just
closing this bishops diagonal and a
three by Duda with rook F to e eight now
adding another defender to the pawn here
but also preparing Bishop to f8 as the
bishop will be well a much better
defender of the g7 square we have Queen
to c2 now with ideas of maybe castling
queenside maybe getting the other Brooke
or over 2g file as well push up to f8
and now H for preparing h5 and g6
we have Queen to c6 by mama d RF now the
Queen also controls the sixth rank but
also the screen better battery could
could become useful in some cases
so d3 adding another defender to the
night here and now a5 here mama Yara
wants to push a4 and create weaknesses
on the Queen side and the Duda doesn't
allow it
first a4 by by Duda and now Knight the
b4 as the before square was just freed
by for his Knight Queen to c3 now
both both of the players have this
battery only only difference is that
well do this battery actually goes for
the g7 square which is never really an
issue the bishop on a fade does a
wonderful job so you don't have to be
all that worried about most of the
tactics Quinta East 6 just a nice
centralizing move with the Queen but
also put pressure on the rook on g4
night after d2 now the bishop protects
the rook so maybe now do I can start
pushing but first be kept resume for be
captors on a4 and not nice to be 6 this
knight now wants to come to d5 and
further harass the White Queen and here
it's very hard to find a move for White
King to ff1 seems like a move white can
play getting the King to some safety no
longer will you have to be worried about
nice to see to check and well the King
is just much safer there but here do the
plate Knight to c4 and this is not the
the greatest of Moose Mammadov played
well he could have gone for night
five but here of course you you're just
gonna move the Queen you can't capture
on e5 because after all the trades the
black would still have nice to see to
check but you can just move Queen to b3
and the game continues however mommy
never found an even better idea he just
captured on c4 we have D captures on c4
and now
well what will you play here I'm not
gonna ask you to pause the video just
you know briefly look at the position
and try to find a move it's just a very
delicate position because here mama
Dianna played rook a to d8 but the
engines are giving that Black has a
winning winning maneuver
although it's very hard to see why this
is a winning maneuver especially in a
rapid game Bishop captures on e4 is the
move and after rook captures Queen to h3
now who would find such a line and now
the thread being Queen to h1 check with
will pick up the rook and after we
prevent this let's say Ruby for now the
bush regards the rook now you go Queen
h1 check push up to f1 and now you
either play E for which threatens
Knights to d3 and the black wood white
would just fall apart here you will not
be able to capture with the bishop as
its pinned and it's just a disgusting
position for for whites to be in on the
other hand if you try something like
let's say after Queen - h1 king - d2 and
you can never use the default because
now rook a to d8 is just deadly the King
has nowhere to go and you will just have
to block with the rock star giving
material and it's game over
so rook a to d8 was not necessary by
Mahmoud Arif as we already saw that the
King can never touch the D file because
rook a d8 comes with with such a deadly
threat but okay that I mean captures and
Queen to h3 is just well I would call it
a disgusting engine line but I wanted
you to see it so kink the f1 by Duda now
getting his Kings the safety no longer
will these two moves be an issue so you
know Lester calculate and now Bishop to
c8 by Monday they are preparing to move
the Queen and then the bishop will be
harassing the rook on g4 but again there
was a much nicer move so here I will ask
you to pause the video and try to find
this very nice I
mommy y'all have had in this position
sorry about not having the sip of water
lately my voice has been fine I don't
really I don't really need the sip of
water but if ever I will need it then I
will have some you know don't worry
about it
so here if you were able to do is
congratulations you are an excellent
lifter of rooks and for those of you
just wanna enjoy the show
look the d4 just create a double attack
against the night here and here white
doesn't really have all that many
choices if you move the night you lose
the rook as the queen and rook or
attacking the g4 rook and your only
other option is to either capture the
rook or to try and guard the night with
f3 and now if you try to guard the night
with f3 it doesn't really add up because
Bishop captures pawn captures and now
rook captures on e4 rook captures and
now Queen to f5 check you cannot block
as the pawn guards this squares you're
probably gonna have to move the King
Queen captures would check King g3 and
now you're just busted with to the King
and g3 and your other option after rook
to d4 is the capture it it captures but
then after it captures the White Queen
is under attack
Queen to f3 defending the knight but now
d3 and now the White Queen just can't
keep an eye on everything you can't
control the d3 squared the rook on g4
and here you can play Bishop d1 but then
Bishop captures on e4 Queen captures
Queen captures you'll get rook captures
rook captures and now black is up only a
pawn but it's it's a deadly pawn it's
it's a passed pawn on d3 and the black
will will win this endgame so this was
one way to go about a roof to d4 but
it's a rapid game you know no you know
no pointing of the finger
Bishop the c8 now by mamedyarov and rook
to g3 Duda just gets the rock our way
and Mamiya repeats we're Bishop to b7
and I'll do the does not repeat rook to
g4 but rather f3 he gets another
defender here and prepares to maybe get
the King to a safer Square Queen to g6
now threatening to capture here and now
Knight to f2 getting the knight out of
the way and h5 now an excellent move by
Medea of not allowing do that to create
any chances with
h5 and also you cannot capture on pass
on as the rook on g3 would hang so first
group the g1 by Judah but now Queen to
c2 hmm
shouldn't have said that my voice is
perfectly fine because you know it's
usually how it goes but Queen to c2
Mahmoud arrow offers a queen trade here
and you don't want trade if captures
captures your rook is under attack and
also the e3 pawn here you would just
fall apart too quickly so Duda tries to
kick away the Queen will rush up to d1
Mamedov pushes the Queen back we have
Queen to f5 and now what do you play
here here probably e4 is the best idea
and just pushing the Queen back and then
maybe trying to consolidate but it will
not be easy but just has a much better
position but okay now with efore you've
numbed the the bishop on b7 but still
this Knight is a monster the rook really
also a monster the queen controlling a
lot of squares here it will be very hard
for white to defend but here Duda played
King to g2 and now it it simply doesn't
work so here again pause the video and
decide what to what to do here with
black I'll give you a couple of seconds
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
solver of tactics and for those of you
who just won't enjoy the show mommy your
played Knights to d3 which is nice but
there is a you know a much more forcing
line which is rook captures and b1 and
it's well you just remove the defender
of the f3 pawn and it's something
probably most people would do but here
it's a rapid game it's not lit so you
can just blitz everything out you have
to calculate properly and it's not a
simple line because if you capture rook
captures here then you get Bishop
captures on f3 with check King g3
worship picks picks up the rug back rook
captures and now E for threatening Queen
to f3 and well you're gonna win the
night so rook the b2 you defend the
night but still Queen f3 trap King to h2
and now Knight the d3 so what do you do
here not really not really a lot you can
do if you capture then you get pawn
captures and
the rook is frita the captured e3 pawn
which will be deadly if you capture with
the rook the guard upon then looked for
threatens the rook captures on h4
followed by rook to h1 mate and if you
prevent that with Queen to e1 just
guarding the pond then rook the g4
threatening checkmate here and after
Luke the d2 blocking now finally Bishop
to d6 a nice deflecting move where you
will have to capture and then Queen g2
not Queen g3 Queen g2 is made so this is
one way to go about it and after this
rook captures on d1 removing the bishop
it's no better capturing with this rook
at this way why just falls apart much
quicker just Queen captures here with
chair King f1 Queen g2 check King to e1
now you get Bishop to f3 and you don't
really have a lot of options here Queen
g1 check will pick up the night here and
well there's really not all that much to
do here you have to move the rook
whatever you do check you move the King
Queen captures with check and again
white falls apart so congratulations to
those of you who found this very nice
idea of rook captures on d1
but Knight to b3 also works very nicely
here what do you do
we have Bishop to e2 by Duda preparing
to bring the other look into the game
also attacking the knight here but now e
4 by mama D are off also a very nice
idea was just Bishop captures and after
we check this game is just you know full
of full of beautiful tactics after
Bishop captures just efore attacking the
bishop if you move it did the Queen
captures on f2 so here it probably
capture on d3 but now Queen captures on
f3 check King to h2 and now rook
captures on d3 again white is just
busted here but my material goes for a
different order of moves with efore
first now comes f4 and now once again
for the last time pause the video and
try to find the winning line form a
media of here I'll give you a couple of
seconds for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations you are an
excellent
continuer of attacks as black and for
those of you just one enjoyed show
tonight captures on f4
no longer can you wait you just have to
bust bust open the position it's check
you are threatening to capture the
bishop here so well white recaptures and
here mom you are just late III it's a
discovered check from the bishop also
the knight on f2 is now under attack
Bishop to f3 was played but now just
Bishop captures with check King captures
and now he captures on f2 with sorry who
would know check but it was in this
position I'll move 36 that young gist of
do that resigned the game and basically
here he dropped out of the feeder grand
prima media of eliminated him what if
you resigned well if you captured upon
the two rooks are just too powerful
just Queen captures on f4 check King g2
and now raakhi to check wins in each
three rook h2 mate and if you don't
capture it well you can't really allow
queen g4 check you have to play King
rook g3 get the rock out of harm's way
but then just work the d3 check wins the
Queen
there's no no nice way to to go about
this King g2 you know you can even play
rook to e1 if the queen is captured just
you you bring your queen into the game
so not really much to do here captures
f1 Queen King g3 Queen captures on d3
with check and here you're just getting
made at Queen d2 check and here
rook III is made so of course do this
all this after upon captures an f2 he
resigned to the game and here as we said
we were gonna check out the standings so
here they are the standings from the
quarterfinals there we have it
Wesley so eliminated Sarah Kerrigan we
already have seen that game with a win
in the blitz format there you have it a
lot of drone games before that then my
Madeira eliminated young she stole Duda
in the second game of the rapid first
game of the rapids was drawn Alexander
Grisha also eliminated you young G in
the rapids in the first game of the
rapids and the Veselin Topalov was
eliminated by maksim buffalo grove
maxime eliminates everyone in the
classical time format you know he
doesn't joke around which is very
strange
maxime won against the polyp in round
one and then in round two where T'Pol
had to win you know stay in the game he
he offered the draw and moved 12 which
was a really strange
I don't know I guess he just thought
that he doesn't have a chance against
Maxime and you know better just maybe
save some rating you know live to fight
another day I don't know but it seems
very strange you know it's still the
classical time format I guess you know
this is a decision none of us can
understand but you know it did happen so
there you have it
Wesley so we'll face my media off in the
semi-finals and Alexander Grisha will
face the maxime beaugeois graph we're
gonna have a really crazy crazy
semifinal matchup so that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Oliver Bond Cheryl Lentz Suzanne
Jones Thomas Libyan and Pavan occur on
Chetty for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here think all for watching and I
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament containing the COPO
Blanc saga and of course checking up on
your suggestions thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day